B.J. Novak played Dunder Mifflin employee
Ryan Howard during The Office's long network
run, but he hasn't latched onto an equally
high-profile project since the series left
the air.
That doesn't mean he's been sitting idle,
however.
This is what B.J. Novak has been up to.
While he definitely isn't appearing on TV
quite as much, B.J. Novak never left television.
The year after The Office ended, Novak had
a cameo on the comedy Community and a recurring
role on Aaron Sorkin's The Newsroom playing
Lucas Pruitt, the owner of the company airing
News Night.
Along with a bit of voice work for the animated
show Arthur, Novak enjoyed a recurring role
as Mindy's ex-boyfriend Jamie on The Mindy
Project and played a satirical version of
himself on two episodes of the musical romantic
comedy series Crazy Ex-Girlfriend.
"Well… back to the old ecstasy factory!"
Novak is also doing a lot more work behind
the camera, particularly in terms of his work
on The Mindy Project.
Just as he did for The Office, Novak has worked
as writer, director, and producer on The Mindy
Project, which isn't surprising considering
his long history with the show's creator and
star, Mindy Kaling.
B.J. Novak was showing interest in more film
work long before The Office shut its doors,
winning small roles in 2007's comedy Knocked
Up, the buddy drama Reign Over Me released
the same year, the 2012 political satire The
Dictator, and most visibly as one of the few
lucky survivors of Quentin Tarantino's 2009
bloodbath Inglourious Basterds.
With the exception of the series finale, Novak
wasn't around for The Office's last season,
and his film credits are probably a big clue
as to why.
Novak was busy in 2013, The Office's final
year, doing more work on the big screen.
He reprised his role as Baker Smurf in 2013's
The Smurfs 2.
That year he also had a small role in the
comedy The Internship and a meatier role in
the comedy-drama Saving Mr. Banks.
The latter film revolves around the development
of 1964's classic Mary Poppins; Novak plays
songwriter Robert Sherman who, with brother
Richard Sherman, co-wrote the film's songs.
The following year Novak played Alistair Smythe
in Amazing Spider-Man 2, a character who may
have eventually gotten some spotlight if that
franchise hadn't died, Smythe is the supervillain
called the Spider Slayer in the comics.
More recently, Novak appeared in 2017's The
Founder, about the creation of McDonald's,
as Harry J. Sonneborn, the McDonald's Corporation's
first president and CEO.
In 2013, B.J. Novak signed a two-book deal
with publisher Alfred A. Knopf, and the following
year his literary career premiered with the
short story collection One More Thing: Stories
and Other Stories.
The book enjoyed a six-week stay on New York
Times' Hardcover Fiction Bestseller List.
"The concept is that I wrote a book, so now
I'm all pretentious."
"People think you're pretentious anyway."
The Washington Post's Jen Chaney described
Novak's writing as being gifted with a style
"...part Steven Wright and part Charlie Kaufman,
married with a sharp ear for (and satire of)
contemporary pop culture."
The next book B.J. Novak wrote targeted an
entirely different audience.
Released after One More Thing: Stories and
Other Stories in 2014, his children's book
The Book With No Pictures spent 55 consecutive
weeks on the New York Times Picture Book Bestseller
List.
If you're wondering how a children's book
that advertises it doesn't have pictures might
appeal to children, well…
"BLORK!
Wait, what?
That doesn't even mean anything!"
The beginning of the book explains, quote,
"Everything the words say, the person reading
the book has to say.
No matter what."
The rest of the book, in large colored letters,
then forces the presumably adult reader to
say ridiculous things that get the kids laughing
like, quote, "I am a monkey who taught myself
to read," or, quote, "My head is made of blueberry
pizza."
In May 2015, news broke that B.J. Novak and
Mindy Kaling were going to collaborate on
yet another project, and this one wasn't going
to be on television.
The same month The Mindy Project was canceled
by Fox and subsequently picked up by Hulu,
the New York Daily News reported that Novak
and Kaling had signed a $7.5 million deal
to write a book "about their off-and-on romance."
The following month, Kaling talking to Vanity
Fair about the deal, saying that she and Novak
didn't, quote, "know all that much about it"
yet.
She explained that they were still in the
early stages with the book and that they weren't
completely sure where they were going with
it save for the fact that, according to Kaling,
it would be, quote, "great and funny."
In spite of what some may have assumed from
the New York Daily News story, however, Kaling
said that while she and Novak would be talking
about their romantic relationship as well
as their friendship, that the book, quote,
"won't be a tell-all."
So far, nothing has materialized as a result
of the deal, but keep your eyes on your local
bookstore.
After he appeared as McDonald's first president
and CEO Harry J. Sonneborn in 2017's The Founder,
in a totally Ryan Howard-esque move, Novak
decided to make life imitate art.
Just like his Founder character, Novak is
hoping to become an innovation supporter…of
meat.
Novak told WWD's Kristen Tauer:
"This sounds sci-fi.
Do you know about the companies that are using
meat stem cells to clone meat in a lab?"
Novak went on to describe the process, saying
it was possible to take the cell of an animal
and, quote, "grow and grow and grow it."
Meaning that, as opposed to the high numbers
of animals butchered for meat now, quote,
"you could just get one unlucky cow and feed
the world forever."
Novak said he supports a number of companies
doing the work and singled out Memphis Meats
as one of them.
Man, Dwight would be so jealous…
"I can get you exotic meats.
Hippo steaks, giraffe burgers."
"We'll talk."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.